on a retrouvé sous la piste future piste
de BMX donc derrière vous en creusant
pareil toujours dans le cadre de ces
fouilles préliminaires on a retrouvé ce
qu'on appelle des gâteaux de Paris alors
je sais pas si vous savez ce qu'est une
Gadou c'est très joli comme ça en fait
c'est une des charges les visites de
sites de chantier ont le vend en poupe à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
celle du Vélodrome en construction à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont affiché
complet énormément de demandes plus que
ce qu'on espérait on n'est pas débordé
mais on est bien sollicité et donc on a
ce créne aussi aujourd'hui et puis
ensuite on a deux samedis par mois
premier et dernier samedi de chaque mois
jusqu'à fin novembre c'est toujours
intéressant d'en savoir un petit peu
plus
sur sur l'environnement sur l'histoire
de Saint-Quentin et puis prochainement
la construction du vélo Drôme j'ai
appris sur tout l'historique sur la
ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines que
j'ignorais totalement
et puis sur son évolution également
jusque là je ne vois que l'extérieur
mais je pense que c'est une belle
architecture qui est assez
impressionnante si vous êtes intéressé à
vous seules les visites de novembre sont
encore ouvertes à la réservation
l'inauguration du vélo Drôme est prévue
en décembre 2013 il accueillera le siège
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
une piste de 250 mètres de long et une
piste couverte de BMX